Ostentatious exaggerated,
colossal big themes that Dubai always
aspires to carry out,
the largest,
most luxurious and most eccentric
projects in the world.
Small territory we can find the tallest
building,
the most luxurious hotel hands.
Even the largest international airport
on the planet's located in a strategic
enclave at the mouth of the Persian
Gulf.
The growth process of Dubai is one of
the fastest in human history.
It just over 20 years.
It has gone from being a remote and last
enclave in the desert to becoming one of
the world's great capitals.
In this period of time,
the Emirates of Dubai has multiplied by
four.
It's population by nine,
the number of visitors and buying eight
the size of its economy.
You said that.
The question is how has all of this
development been achieved?
Has it all just been a matter of oil?
Well,
in this visual politic video,
we're going to talk all about Dubai.
Do you believe is one of the seven
emirates that make up the United Arab
Emirates?
We could describe it as governments as
an Islamic autocracy that restricts the
launch part of people's civil liberties.
However,
if we compare it with neighboring
countries,
do Boeing,
is volume follow the most open place in
the Middle East East?
How about some examples?
Well,
here women can drive.
The van is not mandatory.
You can buy pork at the supermarket and
even alcohol is not hard to come.
Yes,
things are starting to change in a way.
I think we could refer to this city as a
kind of oasis in the middle of the
desert and as you can imagine,
all of this change has had its rewards
and well these rewards,
they might just surprise you.
Did you know that to Bonnie is already
the fourth most visited city in the
world when it comes to international
visitors and that it surpasses
epicenters of tourism and as global
trade such as New York,
Hong Kong or Singapore?
It absolutely is and this is something
that does surprise a lot of people.
Of course,
there's one thing we have to be clear on
here,
do buy.
It does not aspire to be the freest
place on earth,
but they do want to become the richest
was of opulence in this place.
Also evidence that it's not strange to
see the Dubai police patrolling the
streets in Ferrari's on Lamborghini.
Where else
in the world could you possibly see
something like this,
so you might at this moment would be
thinking,
well,
there's an easy explanation for all of
this,
and that is of course oil.
Now,
could it be that Dubai is nothing more
than a dream method is financed with
petro dollars?
Well,
although we cannot deny the influence of
black goals here,
the truth is that the real key to
success is very different.
The secret to Dubai is not oil,
but rather its commitment to trade.
Don't believe me.
Well,
let's dive in a little deeper.
Yeah,
enough oil.
The ends of the 19 fifties,
important oil deposits were discovered
in the vicinity of Abu Dhabi.
The capital of the Emirates.
Take note it because we're not talking
about some small discovery,
but an absolutely huge amounts of oil.
To give you an idea,
it is estimated that the wealth of the
Emirates,
they're proven reserves is even greater
than all the reserves in Russia.
However,
in the case of Dubai,
things that were a little bit different,
it is true that this territory was also
graced with the 14 of black goals,
but it's authorities soon realize that
their reserves were much smaller than
those of their compatriots in Abu Dhabi.
In fact,
the only surprise us oil today accounts
for less than one in every $100 produced
by Dubai's economy.
So you've probably heard about how
important it is.
Do you diversify it and economy rice?
Well,
that is precisely what Dubai did.
They overcame their dependence and their
addiction to wild.
Now,
this is all very easy to say,
but the question is,
well,
how did they do it?
What did you do to achieve such
developments can achieve a higher
standard of living even compared to its
oil rich natives.
Well,
basically what it did was attract a
whole bunch of multinationals and
professionals from all around the world
to achieve this.
The first thing they did was only low
tax policy in Dubai.
They have no income tax.
The tax on profits,
it's practically nonexistent
concurrently.
Purchases and not taxed either or the.
The latter is about to change as the
result of a joint agreement between all
members of the Persian Gulf Cooperation
Council.
Tax on purchases will soon be launched,
however,
the rate is only going to be about five
percent,
which is significantly lower than the
rates we see in developed countries
which tend to be around 18 percent.
Of course in case you were wondering in
Dubai that are no taxes on gasoline.
Yes,
I know it almost seems like we're
talking about another planet,
rice,
but do not think that low taxes are the
only strategy that Dubai has follows not
at all in fact,
seconds and perhaps even more important
than taxes.
You buying his resorted to an instrument
known as a special economic zones like
here,
they are somewhat different to the ones
we can find elsewhere in the wells and
do these special areas in addition to
having tax benefits,
even have their own regulations almost
lost,
which as you can imagine,
are always focused on promoting business
activity precisely thanks to you having
specific rules.
Companies can escape the rigidity of
legal systems that are inspired by
Sharia law applies.
Of course,
to the rest of the Emirates,
we can find a good example of this model
in these so called Dubai international
financial,
which is almost a states within another
state look,
this financial center,
it even has its own judicial system,
Chad,
by the way,
by a British judge and it even has its
own official language which is not
Arabic but English and it's also
replaced the local currency with the US
dollar.
In this way,
a financial institution.
The bank,
for example,
can do business as if it was in
Manhattan,
are benefiting from the tax advantages
of Dubai.
A lot of our deals
right?
Well now we can probably understand how
Dubai has managed to attract most of the
25 largest banks in the world,
but this is not all along with the low
taxes and special economic zones.
Dubai has also opted for a very high
degree of immigration freedom and the
result of all this,
well,
96 percent of its inhabitants,
they've been born a boy.
Wait a second,
because there is still more now to
further boost foreign investments.
At the beginning of this century,
the Dubai authorities made an
unprecedented decision for this corner
of the world,
right?
Being bold.
Governments of Dubai approved a risky
decree that's announced any foreigner
regardless of their religion,
to make real estate investments at that
moment,
the authentic,
but it really began.
I was full of buildings and large
projects,
hundreds of skyscrapers,
gigantic shopping centers,
even it's famous artificial islands.
Now the demand for Dubai became
absolutely global.
It's the fact that since 2002 Dubai has
experienced real estate developments
comparable only to that of Shanghai City
with 13 times more
indeed,
one of the most surprising things about
Dubai is that it has a population of
less than 3 million inhabitants just
like this,
where before there were only a handful
of skyscrapers.
Thanks to this decree that are now
hundreds and huge projects are
announced,
one after the other.
B,
this new skyscrapers,
ferris wheels,
theme parks,
whatever.
One of these latest projects,
by the way,
is known as the mall of the wealth.
It's a gigantic space designed to become
the largest shopping center in the world
hands,
which will even has its own cultural
districts with dozens of theaters and
cinemas.
100 hotels,
the largest indoor theme park in the
world.
The project has been presented as the
world's first city with a temperature
controlled environment.
All
of these measures have made Dubai a
place where it is easy to do business
until he turns.
This mrs into a commercial,
touristic financial,
logistical,
and Steven industrial power.
Yes.
Anyone who thinks that all Dubai,
Isabel is banks and hotels is very,
very wrong nowadays.
Dubai largely thanks to its modern ports
and special zones is the third largest
exporting power in the world ends.
It's industrial production exceeds
$50,000,000,000.
Every single.
Yeah.
Is what explains why its neighbors are
on easily watching any fall in the price
of oil.
While the government of Dubai continues
to carry out and large projects.
It is true from a strictly political
points of view that there aren't many
reprehensible elements when it comes to
religious,
social or human rights issues.
For example,
that all the painful conditions suffered
by many construction workers from
countries such as India,
Bangladesh,
or Pakistan.
Now,
of course we cannot ignore this reality,
but we cannot not pay attention to the
achievements of this emeris among other
things,
because of this growth,
divine has managed to influence the
policies of its neighbors and they are
beginning to reduce their dependence on
oil as well.
Dubai is quite simply a great model.
Consider it,
for example,
the new Saudi Arabia onto Mohammed bin
Salman.
This is something we actually spoke
about in a previous video.
Anyway,
I think this case puts a very important
question on the table.
Is it possible to reconcile the absence
of civil rights with sustainable
economic growth?
Overtime?
No history and empirical evidence seems
to show that this is not the case,
but in a world increasingly pressured by
very high taxes and regulations of all
kinds,
Dubai's authorities seem intent on
demonstrating that this time it will be
possible at the moment.
Spitz commitment to free trade and
investments and its policies aimed at
strengthening legal security,
ease of doing business and keeping taxes
low have been supportive.
If anything,
do you buy shoes?
It's the competitiveness and trade tend
to have better results in terms of
developments than protectionism or
subsidies.
Many rules should pay attention to the
successes of this oasis in the desert,
but that's our opinion here,
visual politic,
and now we'd love to know what you
think.
Do you think the divine model will make
the Middle East a freer place?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoy this video.
If you did,
please do hit that like button and do
not forget to subscribe for brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday.
Also,
please do check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine and as always,
thank you.